for the last lesson of the week we're
going to learn how to cross both poi
same direction the same time at the same
time
take both poi but have your left wrapped
up in your hand face this way with me
get both hands going forward so one PO
is flying but you're moving both hands
is if you've got to play okay that right
boy you're gonna cross over the other
arm and under the other arm and in both
cases it's kind of get yourself a hug
you go
I love me oh I love you so much yeah you
can give yourself in a bug hug or a
below hug so you can put your right on
the top or the right below and you can
also hug and stay there for a longer hug
now hug the other way long hug okay then
wrap up the right and you gonna do the
same thing with your left you can do a
few crosses maybe just to make sure just
crossing forwards then you're going to
hug cross hug cross under hug cross over
over and holds under and hold
over and really hug up I'm Darrin really
hug okay once all of that's working you
get both poi going and guys you might
want to kind of put like one knee in
front just you know just in case
so just kind of be ready to protect
yourself and you're gonna go boom boom
and have one above boom then the other
one above boom you can cross them hold
boom cross and hold the other way boom
and play with that and it probably will
come pretty quickly for most of you
alright until your kaboom and back and
move moon back left on top then right on
top and left on the top and right on top
off this turn so you can see from here
left on top and right on the top left on
top and right I can hold boom the other
way and hold then go through all the
same steps backwards going backwards
yourself and plug with your arm on top
underneath and back above and back back
if you get confused always go back to
the beginning of what are you doing
you're crossing the play backwards right
you remind your body this is all it is
it's just you know how to do it now you
just cross the play backwards make sure
it's going backwards
kaboom backwards get across it
then have the other arm involved but
this isn't changing it's just crossing
backwards you're just kind of adding
that hugging motion then you do that
with the left boy first see it's just
crossing backwards you know how to do it
then the other arm it doesn't work just
keep showing your body like it's just
it's don't worry buddy it's just this
breathe it's just going backwards throw
it over the shoulder but missing the
poof-poof
other arms there it doesn't change
anything whether it's above or below
this is really to you as much yeah
when both arms can do this cross both
backwards if it doesn't work go right
back to the beginning and just keep
building up from the beginning remember
the beginning is one poi just showing
your body it's just crossing backwards
adding the other arm okay its way then
then the left arm boom boom boom boom
and then both yeah what some people will
do is they'll go through the lead ups
really quickly and then spend a long
time frustrated with the end result not
working just keep going right back to
the beginning and building up again and
that's how you'll get there so you want
to be able to cross forwards alternating
which ones on top and cross backwards
alternating which one is on top and they
give you things like this you can go
backwards do a turn be some forwards
crossing do a turn some backwards
crossing a turn forwards Crossing a turn
backwards crossing you can start adding
your turns and the crosses and this is
where you're starting to dance
[Music]
hopefully it was out live jazz music
happening for you too
[Music]
so the way you're going to get
comfortable and kind of good at this the
way you hear in the dance is never move
on too quickly each step of the way play
with whatever wherever you're at each
week until you're feeling like you're
dancing with it you know I'm not doing
like I'm just doing across simple turns
but I'm starting to do it rhythmically
and as a dance and you're better off
dancing with simple things and being
frustrated with more complex things so
we'll see how that works I hope you can
get some nice music playing
[Music]